hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer a question from one of
my newsletter readers chief who runs a
gym and is looking for ways to improve
his profitability and turn the company
around so ajith some ideas for you I
think the most important thing you can
work on is the engagement of your
audience one of the biggest things you
see every January with Jim's is
everybody's kind of hitting the gym
trying to make those new year's
resolutions work and then the rate drops
off hugely you don't see people going to
the gym anymore after January and then
it's another big rush the next year so
the thing for you I think would be how
can you make those people stick around
how can you get that engagement level
high because if people are committed to
your gym they're going to come more
often they're going to spend more money
with you they're going to sign up for
some classes they're going to bring
their friends with them so how can you
keep that system so people want to come
back to your gym so some things to look
at you may want to have free classes to
encourage people to come in you may want
to have workshops with experts for again
for your current customer base to come
back make sure they keep coming back
offer some special days where they can
bring their friends in look for
different ways to get that engagement
level high if it's sending them emails
calling them try to keep them motivated
maybe you have a goal sheet at the gym
to how people fill out their goals and
keep track of how they're doing
basically want to try to find ways to
get that motivation level high so they
keep wanting to come back and spend time
with you if you can do that you've
solved a huge problem that most of the
gyms are facing and if you have those
repeat people coming back again they're
bringing their friends are spending more
money on your gear and classes etc so
Doug be the first nut I try to crack to
get your business even more profitable
you can also look at different ways that
are you know low-cost marketing to bring
more attention to your business one can
be to partner up with other business
owners so you know you promote them they
promote you type of thing local
businesses that are kind of located
around where you are and then I'd also
try to partner up with some media
outlets position yourself as an expert
whenever there's articles that they need
an expert to comment on health fitness
related you want to be the go-to person
to be able to
to those questions and you make a kind
of little splash with your local media
again get well-known get people coming
into the gym but your biggest thing is
still that engagement so if you get
people to come in you don't want them
just a stick for a couple weeks you want
them to stick for the whole year bring
their friends spend lots of money with
you so hope that helps for anybody
watching the video I love to hear your
thoughts if you want to leave a comment
on the video and if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up I love seeing
those and we'll see you on the next
episode
you